ich bin ja seit jetzt über 22 jahren
trockener alkoholiker ich war 16 jahre
profi 16 jahre 14 jahre
medikamentenabhängig vier jahre
spielsüchtig habe mich dann daraus
geholt und bin jetzt unterwegs in ganz
deutschland suchtprävention seit zehn
jahren ich bin auf der straße ich habe
sogar im experiment teilgenommen und war
in frankfurt am main nun habt ja bei
minus 16 grad zweieinhalb tage nächte
verbracht und habe mir das ganze
angeschaut es war absoluter wahnsinn
weil ich selbst weiß was auf der straße
passiert wir sind für suchtprävention
unterwegs ich verbiete nicht ich komme
ich her und seiner familie jetzt in
alkohol wirklich die pro ich habe die
probleme damit gebe ich konnte das nicht
kontrollieren und bin deswegen habe
alles verloren alles was ich mir
aufgebaut habe verloren bin aber wieder
aufgestanden und heute kümmern wir uns
um menschen um kinder und ich gehe nicht
hin und sagen wir müssen alles verbieten
einig mit 60 jahren erreiche die kinder
in der schule mit 14 15 jährigen die
höheren mir zu soll das sind die themen
die sie wissen wollen heute alkohol
drogen medikamente
internethandys vilsen amphetamine unser
lacht unser land wir leben in einem
suchtkranken land und das ist das was
ich sehe weil er jeden tag auf der
straße bin vor zehn jahren bin ich
ausgelacht worden weil ich gesagt habe
wir müssen prävention wir müssen in
schulen wir müssen mit den kindern reden
wir müssen mit den erwachsenen reden wie
erwachsene sind die vorbilder für unsere
kinder und wenn sie das sehen was da
draußen abgeht das hat nicht mehr viel
mit vorbild zu tun morgens um zehn wenn
die kinder fußball spielen stehen zehn
eltern damit der pole das kann nicht
sein und ich sage wir brauchen einen
verantwortungsvollen umgang wir müssen
die vorbilder sein weil wir schaden
unserer gesundheit das soziale leben
geht kaputt die finanzielle krise kommt
noch obendrauf und eins ist ja auch klar
menschen die mehr belastet sind die
jeden tag druck hektik und stress
driften ab in die sucht und da sitzen
wir uns für ein ich habe in dem buch
gelesen haben sie ja ich habe heute
häufig an durchgelesen und angeschaut
und da fand ich ganz spannend wie sie
beschrieben werden auch als fußballer
auch in dem vorwort dass sie eigentlich
fehlendes talent was andere mehr hatten
durch fleiß und disziplin weg gemacht
haben eigentlich etwas was viel
bewundernswerter zweimal vom talent
christus haben sie denn schon während
ihrer profikarriere auch getrunken und
er waren sie da noch komplett an shrek
nein ich war 16 jahre parallel
alkoholiker die alkoholkrankheit ist ja
eine schleichende krankheit der körper
brauche alle jahre mehr ich sage ihnen
jetzt mal in den letzten jahren in
bremen habe ich ein tageskonsum gehabt
dadurch getrunkene kiste wie eine
flasche wodka flasche wissen wie haben
sie das geschafft wenn dann sie gelobt
werden in dem vorwort dafür dass sie
diese disziplin und diesen willen hat
iris wie gut werden sie denn gewesen
wenn sie nicht gesoffen hell nicht viel
besser es nicht viel besser
das haben wir alles nachgeschaut ich
hätte vielleicht vom alter her
vielleicht ein jahr noch länger in der
bundesliga spielen können oder im
ausland ich habe wahnsinnig viel glück
gehabt das haben wir jahre später
festgestellt
der stoffwechsel eines menschen ist
immer anders und ich habe teilweise bis
drei uhr morgens gesoffen und warum 9
uhr der erste um trainingsplatz ich habe
keinen dicken kopf gehabt mir war nicht
schlecht und ich bin vorweg marschiert
wie das alles funktioniert hat mit dem
körper zu tun mit dem stoffwechsel der
ein oder andere trinkt am freitag mal
ein glas wein oder zwei und hat sonntags
immer noch kopfschmerzen bei mir war das
nicht so und so bin ich heute auch durch
ville durch ehrgeiz durch fleiß habe ich
mir das alles erarbeitet er und heute
sage ich ihnen auch das habe ich vor
zwei jahren noch nicht gemacht erst
nachdem ich da zwei tage und zwei nächte
bei 16 grad minus heute bin ich stolz
auf die 22 einhalb jahre ja weil das ist
ein viel größerer schritt ich habe
einige titel gewonnen ich habe dreimal
gegen maradona gespielt aber wissen sie
jeden tag den ich trocken bin der ist
für mich wichtiger wie jeden titel den
ich mal gewonnen habe und so gehe ich in
die schulen so bin ich unterwegs so
versuche ich allerdings auch durch
corona wahrgenommen dass das zunimmt das
trinken der gesellschaft die
psychologische probleme durch die
kommune haslam müssen die korona hat
einen flächenbrand ausgelöst wir werden
so viele suchtkranke menschen bekommen
und psychisch belastete menschen und die
psyche und die sucht wie geht so
ineinander über menschen die psychisch
belastet sind die existenzängste haben
die nicht mehr wissen wie sie die kinder
ob sie dennoch schon kaufen können oder
nicht die rutschen ab in die sucht
vielleicht auch erst wenn die
medikamente oder wie auch immer oder sie
bringen sich bringt sich um viel mehr
kinder die auch eben mit dem sport
aufgehört haben ich habe jetzt ein
neuesten studie über zwei millionen
kinder gehen nicht mehr tagtäglich zum
sport hier sind überwiegt übergewicht ja
wir haben 13 13 millionen menschen die
armutsgrenze leben wir haben im land
bremen 38
prozent kindes armut aber in bremen
streiten sich die politiker wer oder
unter oder über der brücke darf seit
zwei jahren der fahrradfahrer fahren
dahinter wird mir anders das sind wo das
sind doch keine probleme das sind
probleme wenn die kinderarmut da ist
wenn die kinder abrutschen und ich sehe
es ich sehe es tagtäglich und dann
kommen noch politiker her und sagen
cannabis legalisieren
das wäre sache der politiker darüber
geben cannabis legalisieren ist ja auch
in ihrer partei um beispielsweise aber
vor allem wenn sie jetzt hören was die
korona maßnahmen ausgelöst haben es ist
denn dann richtig dass eigentlich ja die
ampel den weg bereitete das massen
fliegt beispielsweise in schulen wieder
ab herbst umsetzbar ist also man kann
ich sagen ich bin sehr froh dass wir
jetzt in der regierung sind und das ist
halt nicht zu locker uns kommen wird und
zu keinen schul schließt man sich da wie
in der 1 ich denke ich denke dass ich
denke dass ein ganz großer unterschied
zu dem vorgänger regierung dass wir
gesagt es gibt keine lockt es gibt keine
schulen was ja in china übrigen auf
frühestens ab der fünften klasse und
auch nur wenn es eine ernsthafte
gefährdung des des präsenzunterricht es
gibt weil wir schulschließung da müssen
sehr vermeiden wollen herausgerufen ja
ja das ist gar nicht so einfach dieses
tatbestandsmerkmal zu erfüllen da muss
man schon einiges schaffen und ich denke
dass das ein deutlicher unterschied ist
zudem und die probleme die entstanden
sind und da der vollkommen recht ist
dass wir zum sport treiben an frischer
luft er habe hinter freiem himmel
untersagt haben für kinder das war eine
große katastrophe kinder brauchen kinder
um zu wachsen ja um brauchen soziale
interaktion
nicht kennen so ein bisschen die
geschichte aber das noch mal so zu hören
und und und und so dabei zu sein und zu
sehen was da geleistet haben das ist
unglaublich und wirklich super respekt
wer was sie sagen mit den kindern ja ich
mein jüngster sohn musste der konnten
auch sport machen auf der dann mit maske
bei 30 grad rumrennen draußen war es
noch schule war
aber was ich heute gelesen habe ist gab
hier so ein programm um die schulen
auszustatten mit lüftern
energie nein noch schlimmer 200
millionen euro waren bereits 22 prozent
abgerufen also 5 44 46 millionen euro
der lässt nicht die sprache hat kein
mensch sich geholt weil zu komplizieren
zur auf wen genau das ist das
genehmigung und ging hin und her das
programm ist mittlerweile ausgelaufen
160 millionen liegen da viele viele
schulen haben diese länder nicht und
warten nur darauf dass der herbst
beginnt bis dann wohlmöglich wieder dann
die maßnahmen kommen die sie beschrieben
haben und ob das nun ab sechster klar
saison siebter ist mir wirklich völlig
egal das ist jede klasse die da rein
kommt weil diese lüfter nicht da sind
nicht abgerufen werden ist eine zu viel
die anfrage der travellers gekommen
wir haben sehr früh das einführen von
diesen luftfilter systemen schulen
gefordert wir haben uns unbedingt sehr
stark für gemacht dass das passiert
berlin hat auch ein eigenes
landesprogramm aufgesetzt auch nicht
regieren muss man sagen da wurde einiges
geschafft aber ich muss ich
widersprechen
ich muss ich widersprechen wenn sie
sagen es ist egal auf welcher klasse
dann ist es nämlich nicht in den ersten
vier klassen habe ich die
schuleingangsphase da ist noch sehr viel
lesen schreiben rechnen die grundlagen
winkler
brauche ich ja das ist vollkommen ich
aber ich brauche gerade in diesen
klassen den kontakt zum lehrer den
augenkontakt ich muss sehen wie werden
laute gebildet das dass wir das auf
jeden fall schon mal gestoppt die
kindliche bildung
das ist wieder gelten kann ist eine
möglichkeit die unter bestimmten
voraussetzungen werde stehe dann hinter
den mavs damit wenn die schulschließung
vermieden werden kann dadurch ja weil
schulschließungen eine große katastrophe
sind ich kann nur eins sagen das will
ich mich immerhin kein kinderschutz ist
mein thema mein thema seit neun jahren
mache ich kenne ich schon ne weile bei
mir machen weder prävention ich
gewaltprävention und ich kämpfe gegen
missbrauch und gegen gewalt und gegen
das man kinder quert der fall jetzt in
europa zum beispiel eine geht das unfall
und viele viele andere weil ihr den
kindern angetan habt ihr die politik auf
dem rücken der kinder
wir haben euch davor gewarnt dass der
missbrauch steigen wird dass die gewalt
steigen wird wir haben eine 4 100
prozentige zunahme von suiziden wollt
ihr fangt mit dem schwachsinn schon
wieder an ihr habt nichts evaluiert ihr
habt diese maßnahmen nicht evaluiert die
maden wurden aber das heißt nicht dass
masken in der schule zu missbrauch
führen ist ein blödsinn
schulschließung und die fehlende soziale
kontrolle waren das problem warum wir
mehr misshandlungen hatten zu hause und
jetzt die
schließung verhindern darum müssen wir
kindern die möglichkeit geben aus ihrem
zuhause alle anderen länder drumherum an
der anderen moment fahren alle drunter
und behandelte ganz anders wir machen
immer weiter keine gehören wie genau
darum geht es nach einer ganz kurzen
unterbrechung wie es eigentlich die
anderen länder machen ob man sich ja
eigentlich dafür feiern sollte dass
schulschließungen jetzt erstmal nicht
mehr kommen das gleich